- It's my pleasure to welcome
you to our new facility.
We're, as you gathered, pretty
proud of our space here.
I'm Bobbie Pilette,
I'm director of preservation department
and for the Center of
Preservation and Conservation
for Yale University libraries.
Welcome to our 7th of our
preservation lectures.
This one is sponsored
by Jack, class of '47,
and Betsy O'Neill.
As you will hear from our panel,
conservation needs are evolving.
And to meet those needs,
the spaces are changing.
Though for some of you who saw our space
with some of the equipment
that probably looks familiar
from 15th-century
prints, you're wondering,
"Is it really new?"
Yes, there's lots of new.
Today's conservation labs
deal not only with the old,
but also needs to take into consideration
the new demands and
expanded use of science
and study of cultural materials.
Our panelists have all been involved
in renovations of a space
or a complete design of new spaces.
Full disclosure,
it wasn't until we had assembled the panel
that I realized that all of our panelists
are graduates of the
University of Texas at Austin
library and information
sciences master's program,
(laughter)
and have a certificate in advanced study
in library and archival conservation.
But as the only graduate-level
conservation training program
that focused on libraries and archives,
it's perhaps not a surprise.
So let me introduce our panelists.
I'm going to introduce them
in the order they'll be speaking.
Beth Doyle, who's head of
conservation services department
and the Leona B. Carpenter
senior conservator
at Duke University libraries
where she's been since 2002.
She holds a bachelor's
of arts and photography
from the University of Dayton,
and a master's and advanced
certificate from UT.
She's active at the local and state level,
and has served on several
American Library Associations,
and American Institute for
Conservation interest groups.
Beth was granted fellow status
in the American Institute
for Conservation in 2014.
Our next speaker is Jennifer Hain Teper.
She's the Bud, Veld?
- Velde.
- Velde preservation librarian,
head of preservation
at the University of Illinois libraries.
She began there as head
of conservation in 2001.
She had gotten her master's
and advanced certificate
from UT in 2000.
She now teaches
several preservation and
conservation-related courses
in the graduate school of
library and information science
at the University of Illinois,
and also serves as an instructor
at the Campbell Center
for Historic Preservation.
She designed the University
of Illinois's conservation lab
which opened in 2006,
and edited the 2012 book
The Planning and Construction
of Book and Paper Conservation
Laboratories: A Guidebook.
Our third speaker is Eliza Gilligan.
She's the book conservator
for the university library collections
at the University of Virginia library,
and she's worked there
since March of 2009.
Prior to UVA,
Eliza worked at the Smithsonian
Institution libraries
and Michigan State University libraries.
Eliza designed labs for
all three institutions,
and participated in multiple renovations
and reconfigurations of conservation
and preservation workspaces.
She received her master's
and advanced certificate
from UT in 2000.
And finally there's
our Christine McCarthy.
She is the chief conservator
for the Yale University library
preservation department's
conservation and exhibition services.
She joined the staff in 2008
as the head of the special
collections collection.
In 2010, Christine's
responsibilities expanded
to include the conservation operations
for the general collections.
In addition to exhibition support
and special collections treatment.
She represents Yale University's
conservation committee
as an active member
of Mellon-funded international
project ConservationSpace.
Christine received her master's
and advanced certificate
from UT, and has a BFA in
illustration and design
from the University of
the Arts in Philadelphia.
She's a professional associate
member of the American
Institute for Conservation.
In her previous positions
at the University of Chicago and MIT
she established new programs.
At the University of Chicago
she worked with architects
to design a treatment laboratory
as part of the building expansion
for the Regenstein library.
The way we're gonna structure this
is each of the panelists have
a brief formal presentation,
and then I'll pose a series of questions
that they will start to address.
What we're hoping to do
is start a conversation.
So we'll go through those
series of questions.
You each have an index card,
there's a pencil floating
around somewhere in your row.
Feel free to jot down questions.
We are recording this
and the microphones you
see are for the recording,
we're not amplifying anything.
We also have an overflow room
where there's some folks,
and so they will be the ones that will
have to rely solely on the index cards.
We'll have somebody bringing them in.
But for those of you here,
you are free to ask the question yourself.
But if you don't want to
you can pass the index card
to the center of the aisle
when I call for that and
someone will take it up
and I'll simply relay the
question to the panelists.
So please join me in
welcoming our panelists,
and Beth will be the first one to speak.
(applause)
- Good afternoon.
Oh, so in the South, I should say,
that you have to respond
to that or it's very rude.
Good afternoon.
(crowd responds and laughs)
I learned that lesson really quickly.
So I wanna thank Yale and
Bobbie for inviting me today,
and thank you all for coming.
This is a beautiful space
and we appreciate you sharing it with us.
The Duke University library's
Vern and Tanya Roberts Conservation Lab
is a hybrid lab,
that is we work on both
special collections
as well as general
collections in the same space.
I was hired in 2002 to develop
the conservation program.
At the time we had three
technicians and myself.
Our space consisted of two
large rooms that you see here,
separated by a semi-public hallway,
and we shared both of these
rooms with the Bindery Unit.
Our supplies were in that
hallway on pallets on the floor
and on hand-me-down shelving.
My staff was really productive
despite the fact that
they spent a lot of time
and physical energy working
around the limitations
of that space.
We had no room for growth,
we didn't have space to
add a lot of equipment,
and this really limited
the types of treatments
that we could do,
especially for special collections.
The good news was that the
library had already embarked
on a major renovation
that included a new conservation lab.
We moved to temporary space
on the medical campus in 2006,
and the new lab was opened in 2008.
The new lab was purpose-built for us.
We have adequate space to move
around and store supplies.
And we were also able to
install a lot of large equipment
as well as things like fume
hoods and washing sinks.
Duke University is also very committed
to having good ergonomic workspaces,
and because of that we have a cork floor,
electric sit-to-stand
benches for everybody,
and special ergonomic
chairs at each bench.
The new space allowed us
to improve our workflows
to better control our supply inventories,
which means better budget control, right?
And improve our documentation practices.
We also have room to add staff
or spread out if a treatment
demands that space.
Most importantly, it
allowed us to envision
a more robust and integrated
conservation program
for the library.
We were able to expand our
services to include mold removal,
chemical treatments, washing,
and humidification and flattening.
It also allowed us to
develop and expand services
for the exhibits program and
the digital production center.
And if you're interested to
see a video tour of the lab,
there's one on YouTube at that link.
The greatest benefit of this space
is the opportunities that
is affords our program.
We recently hosted Gawain Weaver's
photograph conservation for
non-photo conservators workshop,
and we invited about 15
people plus the instructors
into the space.
We also hosted an object conservator
who spent a few days working in our lab
on items from our history
of medicine collection.
Having the flexibility to
have conservators come to us
exposes us to other
conservation specialties,
and builds our conservation community.
I'm very interested
in doing more of these sorts
of things in the future,
and our space really allows us to do that.
The lab has become a major stop
on the library development office tour.
We give tours to students and faculty,
advisory board members, donors, alumni,
and colleagues interested
in renovating their labs.
Most importantly, our space and services
are highlighted on tours for donors
whose collections they
are considering depositing
at our library.
The work we do is a value-added service
that we can provide for their collections,
and shows our commitment to
the care of those materials.
And last year,
we received a donation to
conservation's adopt-a-book fund
as a direct result of the
behind-the-scenes tours we hosted
on alumni weekend.
So it was really exciting
to be part of the outreach
and fundraising efforts of the library.
I believe by engaging
our library colleagues,
the academic community,
and donors in these ways
we not only get to show
off our work and space,
but we can demonstrate
that we are a key component
in making collections accessible,
and are an integral part
of the life of the library.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Hi, thank you all.
- [Person In Audience] Hi.
(laughter)
- I'm from Pennsylvania, I
don't have the same requirement.
I'm here representing the
University of Illinois's lab.
I think I actually have the oldest lab.
Our lab is now 10 years old.
This is a picture from the good old days
before we moved over.
This is as nice as our old space got.
I want to point out a
couple of highlights,
other than our fantastic staff, of course.
Our old space was, as many of you know,
or have similar experiences,
in the basement.
We did have garden-level lighting
which looked out onto the
very scenic loading dock
which sucked in fumes periodically,
which was really nice.
We had the most fantastic
matching 1950's vintage
all-steel office furniture ever.
Which was exceedingly
non-ergonomic (laughs)
and really didn't offer
very good workspace.
But obviously we made it work.
The biggest hindrance
here to our old space
and the big reason for
pushing for a new lab
was that there was absolutely no water
or chemical treatments
possible in this space.
It was just a basement
space in our library.
And so our goal was to
get out of our space
and off of that floor entirely
before we clogged up the women's room sink
with so much PVA buildup
that everybody hated us.
Cuz there was only one sink
to wash out all of our brushes in.
And it was shared with the laboratory.
Good news is that when I came
to the University of Illinois in 2001,
there was hope.
(laughter)
The library had embarked on,
like many other academic libraries,
funding to build a Harvard-style
high-density storage facility.
And in that was planned
a conservation lab.
So when they hired my position
as the first head of conservation,
the plan was to entice me
with this forthcoming conservation lab.
That was 2001.
In 2003, when they actually
built and finished,
well 2003-2004,
finished the construction
on the high-density storage facility,
they recognized that they had not budgeted
nearly enough money for the
very hi-tech HVAC system
that high-density book storage requires,
and the only thing you can
actually cut out of that budget
was the conservation lab,
because everything else was book storage.
So then there was a lot
of heavy fundraising
to make the lab happen,
which is why I'm now at the
Bud Velde Conservation Lab.
Thank goodness for Bud Velde
at the University of Illinois.
So we moved into that
space actually, in 2006.
Simple floor plan,
simply because our space
doesn't photograph real
well, unfortunately.
Lots of long, skinny spaces.
But just to give you an overview
of what we have in the space.
Obviously a nice big lab
space, wet lab, et cetera
I'll show you some individual pictures.
Ample office space for staff growth,
which we have almost
completely encompassed now
within 10 years.
I thought we had more space
than we could possibly use.
After 10 years
we filled up pretty much every
single niche in this lab.
Dirty space, which I'll be
talking about in just a second.
But most importantly, we have this giant
conference room/reference
space/classroom/everything else.
And that has honestly been
one of the most valuable spaces for us
because we do a lot of education
with our graduate school of
library and information science.
We do a lot of donor
relations and bring people in
and kind of do a lot of
orientations in there.
But it's also great surge
space for us to have,
you know, the random, huge,
moldy collections that come in
that we need to put somewhere.
It's great to have an extra
surge space built like that.
I would say that this whole square footage
is about 5,000 square feet.
And I was really, really, really proud,
I am still,
very proud of our lab.
But I have to say that coming here
and seeing the beautiful
facilities at Yale
has been maybe wah-wah-wah (laughs)
(laughter)
Illinois, uh. (laughs)
But you guys still have the
new car smell on your lab,
and mine's worn off, so.
Okay, so looking at the space,
we have fantastic natural light.
We actually may have too
much natural light now.
Despite shades and whatnot,
we do find that in the winter months,
sometimes it still gets
a bit bright in our lab.
But it's so much better
than being in a basement.
The natural light is obviously fantastic.
Almost nothing is fixed in our lab.
Everything is mobile,
which has turned out to be essential
as our program has changed.
And that's one of the things that I think,
because I came in when there
almost really was no program
at the University of Illinois.
We were one of the first
labs that was funded
as part of the Mellon
Foundation initiative
to start building labs
in institutions that didn't have them.
So when I came in,
I was the head of conservation,
and the only person in conservation
other than one book-repair tech.
And we've grown to six
FTE and 2.5 hourlies.
2.5 FTE hourlies at this point.
So planning for how those
people were gonna use that space
was kind of challenging
when you're designing a lab
with no staff there yet.
And so the fluidity and the
mobility of all that equipment
was really, really important.
We've got one little wall of
built-in cabinets and whatnot.
But absolutely everything
else is mobile and adjustable.
And ergonomic and height-adjustable
and everything else.
All those good things.
We do have the essential
wet lab, obviously.
This is one of the areas that
I didn't plan very well for.
I'm a book conservator,
or was a book conservator,
I should say, unfortunately,
and so when we designed this lab,
I'm thinking "books."
Then we hired a paper conservator.
You paper conservators take up
a phenomenal amount of space.
Oh my god.
So when our paper conservator came,
we had to re-think not only
the layout of the general lab,
which I said was mobile,
so we made it work,
but the wet lab has now kind
of become her territory.
And so what I though
ample, six-foot fume hood,
is no longer ample for
our paper conservator.
So now we have to look at
we're actually actively
installing a snorkel system
to make basically every
working surface in that space
suitable for fume evacuation,
which it was not, previously.
And then of all the rooms
that I wish we had more square footage,
we have our dirty/quarantine space,
which is really much more quarantine
than it ever has been dirty.
Although it gets dirty, but
in the really yucky sense.
This is where anything buggy,
wet, pooped-on, moldy, et cetera,
comes in and gets quarantined.
And we have been shocked
by the embrace from our
special collections units
in having this space and bringing in
all of their disgusting gifts
into our space for us to deal with them.
This looks really empty
and almost spacious.
Usually every surface in here
is covered with something, unfortunately.
Because our buildings are very old
they leak like a sieve,
and we're always getting in gross gifts.
So I wish I could triple
the size of this room.
Alright.
Thank you, and we'll move on.
(applause)
- Hi everyone.
Let's see.
The University of Virginia library.
I am the first book conservator
ever hired by the university library,
which is kind of amazing
considering the scope of
their rare book library.
But the program was underway
briefly before I got there.
Holly Robertson was the
previous head of preservation.
She had a nascent book repair unit.
There was a commercial binding operation,
and then she wrote a Mellon grant
to sort of be like Jen said,
start a conservation
lab, hire a conservator,
and then create an endowment
to fund the preservation
administrator position.
So things happen, you write
a grant, you have a plan,
you think it's just
gonna go like clockwork,
and then things change.
When Holly wrote the grant,
she thought that the university
was going to coalesce around this idea.
She had brought on board
the university art museum,
the office of the architect,
and the Kluge-Ruhe Art Museum,
which is a huge collection
of Australian Aboriginal bark paintings.
And she had identified
a building on campus
just a little bit apart
from the main campus
that we could build a big
collaborative conservation facility
sort of something like this,
maybe a little smaller.
Just a conservation facility.
So she wrote the grant with that in mind,
they hired me with that
in mind, the idea being,
"This is all gonna happen,
this is all gonna happen,"
so by the time I moved to Charlottesville
and show up on my first day, they're like,
"Well, things have changed a little bit.
"We're still gonna do
"the collaborative conservation facility,
"but meanwhile we have
"a temporary conservation space for you
"in a swing space
building on campus, where,
"when we're renovating the art studios
"we put their offices."
So they gave me this space,
which was formerly a photography dark room
for the art studio.
And Holly's original plan
for this space had been,
"Oh, they're gonna give
us 2400 square feet,
"and we can put in book repair,
"we can put in box-making,
we can put in supplies,"
and this that and the other.
The university said,
"No, no, no.
"You get this end of the building.
"663 square feet."
And so all the big plans
had to be scrunched down.
But it was only gonna be temporary.
So, "Plan this, but also
plan your future lab,
"and then figure out how
you're gonna integrate it
"with the book-repair unit
"that you actually aren't
gonna be contiguous with."
But that's what we had in the grant.
(laughter)
So we talked with the Mellon Foundation,
kept them appraised,
but that meant that I was
juggling a lot of concepts
and a lot of workflows
also with the new head of
preservation, Kara McClurken.
So the idea for the conservation lab
was build everything
you can do full service,
just scrunch it up a little bit,
and make sure that everything
we put in that room
can move out of that room
and be implemented in the new facility
and be grown into a new facility.
So that's where we started.
And like I said, 663 square feet.
And the original plan had been
all kinds of custom built-in cabinets
and cubby holes and things
for storage of supplies.
But there was no way I
was gonna be able to do
storage of big supplies,
and the idea of custom
furniture, wooden furniture
that would then move to a
new facility, I was like,
"Okay, that's not gonna work."
And so I changed the concept quite a bit.
I said,
"We're gonna go with the university vendor
"who provides the casework and the benches
"and the countertops for the science labs,
"because they will come in,
"they will do exactly what we want,
"they will give us a good price,
"and then when it comes time to move,
"we can get more casework,
we can get whatever.
"We can build on the original concept,
"and they'll still be around
and it'll all work fabulously."
That was the lab standing at one end,
and you can see that
the sink and everything
hasn't been quite attached.
This is me turning around the other way,
and ta-da, you see the washing sink,
the lockers to hang coats and so on.
And this is before the flat-file
cabinets were installed.
So while this is all going on,
I'm designing the
collaborative conservation lab,
and we're doing donor
packets and brochures,
and everything was gonna be fabulous.
And then things changed.
That investor in New York
turned out to be a fraud,
and a lot of people who had money
then didn't have money.
So it became apparent
that I was really gonna have
to make a permanent home
of this facility.
So seven years in, this is
the facility in working order.
It is just me,
or for most of the time
it has been just me
working in this conservation lab.
Every summer I would hire a
six-week conservation intern.
And then the past few years
I had a graduate intern from NYU.
So I've been able to spread out,
which can be really nice if
all the benches are yours.
(laughs)
And I can really figure
out how things are, y'know,
how do things work.
I can stage treatment really well.
One of the big drawbacks,
though, is I'm very isolated.
I am a 15-minute walk from
the main library buildings,
so we never get donor tours.
Or we've tried, we have open houses.
People don't really come,
or it's pouring rain,
and then nobody really wants to come.
One open house we had this lady
who trudged through the rain
with her husband holding
the umbrella over her,
and she desperately wanted
to see the conservation lab
because years ago she had been
interested in conservation.
And her life took another turn,
and there and then she pulled out a cheque
and wrote me a cheque for $100.
Which was really, really sweet,
but that's the level of
engagement you can get
when you are not in
easy strolling distance
from the director's office.
So that's a big drawback.
I also spend a lot of time
running back and forth.
If somebody finds a moldy book
I get off my chair, hustle on over.
If things need quick fixes
in special collections buildings,
I load up my bag with tools
and methyl cellulose or whatnot
and I run over, and I'm like,
"Oh wait, I needed something else,"
because the person
described it a certain way
and they didn't use the terminology.
And again, when you're
the only conservator
at an institution,
you're the one-man band.
You're trying to train the staff
to understand what you
can do, what you can't do,
and how to think about conservation.
So those are some of the drawbacks.
But that said,
you can do a lot in 663 square feet,
although,
do we have a pointer?
Oh, no no.
Come back.
I was gonna say,
if you look back to where the peg board is
over the washing sink,
to the right there's this
sort of big white square box,
that's the air-handler system.
That lab is all we have in that building.
So when the air-handler system died,
the facilities guys were like,
"Well, we've gotta take out the old one
"and put in a new one,"
and you're like,
"Well this is the only
working space I have,
"I'm in the middle of treatment."
What do you do?
You just sort of keep going,
and the fellas were literally
chopping up bits of the HVAC
system and pulling it out,
and then they had to order the new one
and it was bigger than the old one,
and so then they had to take down a wall—
(laughter)
and make the booth for
the air handler bigger.
So I did lose a little
bit of square footage.
Another drawback of this facility
is that there's no temperature,
well there's temperature control,
but no relative humidity control.
If it rains outside,
the humidity goes way up.
And it's no joke, we track it
and my boss and I are still
advocating for a new space.
That hasn't happened yet.
But then again,
the university is going to be renovating
the main library building,
so maybe something will happen there.
The other tricky thing about this space
is that people still don't
know what conservation is,
to a certain degree.
I go to town meetings
and do presentations.
I spend a lot of time with
special collections people,
cultivating them and educating them
on what conservation can do.
But then that means
the rest of the library
doesn't really know.
So outreach is a constant
effort on my part,
and a constant effort on my boss's part.
And then when interns come
I make them give presentations
and things like that.
There you have it.
I think Bobbie's questions for us
will sort of flesh things out.
But on to Yale.
(applause)
- I have slides,
but since most of you have seen the spaces
(laughter)
I don't feel like I have
to work quite so hard
to describe the wonderfulness
(laughter)
that is our new laboratory.
But as Bobbie said,
I'm the chief conservator
for the libraries here.
That means I'm the head of conservation
and exhibit services.
And you met many of the fabulous staff
that I work with to take care
of the library's collections.
My presentation is entitled
Conservation Studio to
Conservation Laboratory.
Some of you may remember or
had seen the space in 1974.
I actually found the
preservation news announcement
when Jane Greenfield had turned
what was a book-binding
studio in the library
into the library's first
conservation studio.
It was sort of considered
state-of-the-art,
all set up, fabulous, good to go.
We continued to work in
that space for 50 years.
As you can see in the top corner
I've got the preservation news.
Some of you might have
remembered that fume hood.
Still usin' it.
It cost $418 in 1974.
And it does not owe us
a thing at this point.
(laughter)
The other pictures are actually
the befores of our space.
This is 2008.
So this is when I arrived
and was hired by the
library to take the post
as the chief conservator.
The top is our space on 1NB,
which is a mezzanine level
in Sterling Memorial Library,
tucked off stacks, off
publicly-accessible hallways,
a tiny 1930's-sized
hallway with book stacks.
So probably about the width of this podium
to access a single door.
No secondary egress.
And an incredibly steep ramp
that got you down into the sit space
because it was sunken below.
The lower picture represents
the fact that at some point
other parts of the
operation as we expanded,
the initial space was the whole space,
so that 1NB, it was
about 1400 square feet.
General collections, at
some point moved to a space
in the basement.
Exhibit functions were also
set up in the basement.
So then we became a program
on two different floors.
We weren't really able to do much
in terms of rearranging
a lot of those spaces.
None of them were really
purpose-built in the basement.
And the experience that Eliza described
for us was sort of a daily occurrence
because most of our
spaces were built around
or contained various parts of
the SML's HVAC water systems,
fire suppression, water sprinkler mains.
You needed to fix
anything in the building,
it was somehow in one of our spaces.
All of the telecommunications wiring
for the entire building.
So we had a lot of traffic
with facilities, outside contractors,
and others from the library
who needed to come in and out.
We did not have any way to add space,
there was absolutely
nowhere to go at this point.
We could shuffle, we could rearrange.
In 2010, Bobbie managed
to secure some money
for us to do a sort of minor renovation
to the spaces that we were using.
That involved new lighting
in the basement, new paint.
We did the most to the lab upstairs
that had started in '74
as the conservation lab.
We added a washing sink
instead of a photo sink,
a very narrow sink that actually,
according to the pictures
in the '74 article,
I don't think we ever washed in the sink,
I think we always washed in trays
outside of the washing sink,
because it was an off-the-shelf
photo-developing sink for
small 8x10 photographs.
So we added those things,
and that sort of bought us some time.
There had been talk about plans
for a centralized facility
of various conservation
operations on campus
on York Street, that York Street building,
that was the first
project when I got here.
There was a very large
plan developed for that.
That did not come to happen.
Yale purchased the West Campus property
that's out in Orange,
and there was talk about that,
building, from scratch,
a purpose-built facility
that would house labs
for all of the conservation
labs on campus.
Due to the crash in 2008
there were some changes where
that project was stalled.
When it re-started,
basically the scientific arm
had become incredibly important.
The idea of building
a shared analytical and research facility,
where we could have folks like,
I see Aniko,
our director of scientific
research for conservation,
and those things sort of took precedence,
and an existing building
needed to be modified.
Also, the art gallery needed
space for its operations.
So that plan turned
into a shared facility.
So there was space at West Campus
where we could use it
on a temporary basis,
but there was not sufficient space
for us to move all of
our operations out there.
Also, because of the way we work,
and as people know with libraries,
we are intimately tied
to the collections here,
and so, with no other library
presence on West Campus,
it seemed difficult to move
our day-to-day operations,
and easier to coordinate
and work at West Campus
for special projects
and for anything that involved a kind of
technical research study of material.
A lot things started to
happen between 2012 and 2014
which basically meant that a program
that was sort of held in
the little bit in stasis
by the walls that existed,
the physical walls,
began to kind of really burst out
and to respond to current
changes in the field and needs.
And so in 2012 conservation and
exhibit services was formed.
General collections had
been a separate unit,
and so that was brought under,
so there was the potential
for that kind of crossover
and cross-pollination in the
ways that we work with things.
We saw that as an opportunity
because Yale has collections
general collections that
really in many places
are considered special collections.
And so there are a lot
of transitional material
that medium-rare concept that
was talked about years ago.
And so we thought it might
be an interesting thing
to think about how we
might have to re-tool
our general collections operation.
Three workspaces, two different floors,
three flights apart from one another,
accessed by very tiny
little winding stairs,
or a teeny tiny elevator
in the public stacks hallway.
As you can imagine, that can be difficult.
We moved photo-doc out of the main lab,
but that went down to the basement,
so that meant every object had to move
up and down three flights
for before and after documentation.
We began to see a real change, though,
in terms of a lot of
outreach to the campus
and thinking about how an internal,
embedded conservation lab
should really facilitate and add something
in addition to what a
conservator in private practice
might bring.
That was being engaged in teaching,
and some of the learning
that's happening on campus with objects.
So as you can see here,
we have a number of examples
of all the different kinds of
things that started happening.
Analytical testing,
working with scientists,
working with faculty, working
with outside researchers.
The lower picture on your left
is our traveling scriptorium in action.
So those are students from,
I believe, Barbara Shailor,
who's with us today,
her class learning to write,
pretending to be scribes at a table.
We did all of that in that tiny space.
Rearranging shutting down
every part of the operation
to make that happen.
And a lot of these things
became very popular.
As most people know in libraries,
we see a lot of oversized material.
So we can't continue to count on things
being small, rare books.
As much as we encourage those purchases
(laughter)
and I see Ray Clemens, who's like,
"Little books."
(mumbles)
We see Tibetan thangkas,
we see large, oversized maps.
We see physical,
three-dimensional objects.
You may have seen the two Coronelli globes
that are in the lab right now.
So the spaces were very
difficult and very challenging
to re-tool and to change for
the different kinds of things
we needed to do.
We also hired Werner Haun who joined us,
and we have a new team in what we call
collections, conservation, and housing.
Lot of new housing projects.
A lot of need out there
to house special, unusual objects,
and just to protect things
that are going to off-site
shelving facilities.
So that became a really
full-blown operation
that sort of transitioned
our general collection
into something else.
So folks were really working
together very closely,
our exhibits program was also growing,
Kerri Sancombe our
exhibits program manager
was beginning to think
about student exhibitions
and working with students
and needing to bring them into the space.
So then we get to the Gates
Conservation Laboratory in 2016.
We are a true hybrid facility,
and for the first time we
really can bring all of those
places together that we had in Sterling
so that the staff who always
worked so well together
and worked very hard at that collaboration
and the seamlessness
in terms of what we did
now have a space that
physically reflects that
and makes that a lot easier.
Our design for the lab
really ended up almost tripling
the existing space we had.
At our top we were
about 3,000 square feet.
Not much of that space in Sterling
was completely useable space.
I mentioned the ramp.
We had an opportunity to
create functional areas
like our wet treatment,
and photo-doc rooms and
things that were separate
from the primary main treatment space
so that people weren't
collapsing or moving
their personal tables and workspaces
so that we could accommodate
what are pretty standard
separate functions
that are now reserved for
people and they can use them.
We stuck with a very open
and flexible floor plan,
and I would say that that is a real credit
to people like Paula Zyats, our
assistant chief conservator,
Marie-France Lemay, and all
of the others on our team.
Karen, and Ansley, and Kerri,
who we had worked so long and so hard
in terms of making the other space work,
that we just kept what
was good about that.
Which was that we need to
be able to change ourselves
as we need to respond to what's there.
And even when you get a lot of space,
which, we got a lot of space,
you still need to really think about that
because no one ever
really has enough space,
and there's just
different ways to do that.
So you'll notice that the
built-ins are perimeter,
not so much in the center.
We kept our original mobile tables,
put in tables to match those
so that we could create
that flexible floor plan.
And I think the other thing
that's made a huge difference
for us as I mentioned,
is critical adjacencies for us.
We are all together,
photo-doc is off the main treatment area,
the collections vault is
right next to photo-doc.
And I think that helps us to stay in-line
with what is really good practice,
because you're not so
tempted so skip a step,
or to think, you know,
"I've gotta take this all
the way down three flights,
"is it really something
I wanna do to this object
"to take a photograph?"
So I think we are able
to do all of the things
that we need to do
so much more efficiently,
and so much better.
We do have a little bit of growth space.
As Beth mentioned, we're looking forward
to not holding Beinecke classrooms hostage
while we have consultants
in to survey collections
or to examine them.
We can host on-site private conservators
because we have the space.
We have never had an intern
in the time that I'm here
from the graduate programs,
because honestly
they would have to sit
on top of someone else.
Would've had to build a loft
or some sort of trailer in
the parking lot for them.
(laughter)
That is something that
we've been asked every year,
and so it's nice for the
first time this year to say
when people call from Buffalo,
"Yes, we would be happy to consider that."
I think that the team has
an awful lot to offer,
and the collections do too.
The other critical thing
for us that I think works,
is that the other parts of
the preservation department
have come with us and
are in the same building.
And more importantly, with
the Beinecke's location here,
they're 90% of our
special collections work.
More importantly,
it just gives a nice,
healthy library presence
to the space
so we don't feel isolated in that way.
And a lot of our work is
back-and-forth with archivists
and librarians from there,
so it makes things really
great and really easy.
So it's kind of a destination.
Bacey is with us today,
too, from development,
and we have had no
shortage of walk-throughs.
People will come.
There have been two classes
that have already come through
in the six months we're here.
And we have had at least
one development tour
or walk-through, or special visit
every month since we've been here,
and we hope that will continue.
Thank you.
(applause)
- Okay, so, switch this...
I do have a series of questions.
Many of the questions have
been addressed in part
within the talk.
But it'll give you the opportunity
to perhaps expand on various areas.
One of the things,
I think almost every one of you mentioned
that your labs are hybrid.
And perhaps it might be good
to talk a little bit about
what that is and what's driven that
sort of way of operating,
and whether that was,
is it programmatic, or then also the space
that it's all in one space.
Is that programmatic that
you've done the hybrid?
Or is it something else
that's causing that?
So, I'll let you figure out
who's gonna answer that first.
(speaking off mic)
- I'll start cuz we have the microphone.
As I mentioned,
it was a conscious decision on our part,
because we had had segregated
spaces for so long.
Obviously kind of
segregated in the extreme.
But we really did see
that in many respects
that Yale's general collections operations
were really changing.
We still see some of the
minor kinds of repair,
but we don't see a lot of
straightforward book repair.
Certainly not the kind that I learned
when I was first a technician.
We see much more complicated
and older materials,
and so this allows us an opportunity
for the technicians to have
very similar transferable skills
and for us to form smaller project teams
that are kind of across all
of those boundaries of skill,
and it just makes things more flexible
and we can be better able
to respond to things.
- As Kara and I have
talked about the future
of the conservation program at UVA,
we had one future that we
thought we were planning for
and with the collaborative
conservation facility
that was going to be built, we thought
"Should we plan to move book repair
"and commercial binding, and everything
"out of Alderman Library?"
And ultimately we decided
that we shouldn't,
because we wanted to
have a physical presence
in the main library.
We didn't want people to forget
what preservation and conservation did,
and if not enough library people
were going to move out
to the remote facility,
whatever it was,
we thought we would be too isolated,
people would not know what we did,
and we would be just some satellite
where mysterious things happened to books
and then they came back
in blue plastic totes
and looked better.
So we had never planned
to move them all together
unless we could be part of
a bigger library facility.
And then with the way things
have worked out at UVA,
I'm the little satellite
and then I spend time
coming back and forth.
I think the hybrid concept,
it creates a lot of flexibility
and I think that's really important
because programs change
and staffing changes,
and you have opportunities
to hire new people,
or people move out of your
department for whatever reason.
So I think having a hybrid
program is really great.
And I think years ago people were saying,
"Book repair's gonna go away,"
and this and that.
It is gonna be a long, long time
before book repair goes away.
So I also think for that reason
we still need to plan for hybrid programs.
- At Illinois we are a hybrid lab.
That was more because
we had no lab to start
and so we had space for one lab.
So it, by essential,
had to be a hybrid lab
because we weren't gonna get
a special collections lab
any time in the near future.
What I didn't mention,
which I think is important,
is that, similar to some other folks,
the Harvard-style facility
that our lab is occupied in
is on the edge of campus.
So we are similar,
about a 15-minute walk.
However, we also have
high-density storage.
Which, for whatever reason,
it really thrills donors.
It's that whole Indiana Jones experience.
So we have no problem getting
donors out to our space.
But the space we moved out into
did require us, similar to UVA,
to separate ourselves from preservation
and a lot of the adjacencies that we have
with the preservation program.
So while the conservation lab is hybrid,
we are separated from preservation,
which gives us a different
sort of separation,
but does bring us back
then to the main library
a lot more frequently.
So within our facility,
we have general book repair,
the way it was constructed we
would have general book repair
and then special collections conservation.
In the 10 years since we
opened the lab, of course,
similar to what Christine
was implying with Yale,
we've watched a lot of changes
in the way we're approaching
our book repair part of it.
And while, no, book
repair is not going away,
it is changing.
And our approaches to it
are definitely changing.
And with the adjacencies that we have
with special collections,
it's allowed us to start
to develop actually third,
a kind of grey in-between
workflow of medium-rare.
And to look at all that material
that is not really rare,
and it's not really general,
but it's somewhere in the middle.
And to be able to collaborate
and to work with people who
have some of the skill sets
that are more appropriate
in special collections
even though the material doesn't
sit in special collections
has allowed us a lot of
programmatic flexibility
to do what we feel is really appropriate
for our collections.
Being, similar to all of us here,
a large academic library,
our print's not going anywhere.
But our print is going to
become more and more important
as an object over time.
And so I think the hybrid approach
is really important for us
to be able to care for a
massive general collection
in a way that's important long-term
not just slapping book
tape on it or whatever.
- Ditto.
(laughter)
- You won't go last next time. (laughs)
- I don't know what else to add to that,
other than I think it's
one thing to look at it
from a collections standpoint,
but I'll just touch on what it does
in terms of staff development.
Having a hybrid lab
really allows people to participate
either directly or indirectly
in skill-building discussions
that they might not get
to do all of the time.
Our technicians are all
trained, to some extent,
to do general collections work
and special collections work.
So if there's an all-lab project
and we need all hands on deck,
they have the skills to do that.
And I think that is really important
because we hear a lot of rhetoric
about how the general
collections aren't important,
they're going away, we don't need them.
And we know that it's not true,
and we're actually the
physical manifestation
of the fact that that's not true.
And so I think that hybrid space
really allows us to
show why it's important
that all of these skills are needed,
and that the staffing
levels we have are needed
for the collections that we have.
- [Pilette] Let me ask one more question,
then we'll open it up.
What I wanted to ask is,
in your planning and design,
to what extent and in what ways
were you able to anticipate
the non-treatment things
that you're having to deal with?
Beth, you get to go first.
(laughter)
Or do you want more time to think?
- See, that's the hard part, right?
Doubling our space allowed us to do that.
Just moving through
our old space was hard.
Having the space to store things
or to review things
or to have curatorial conversations
is really important.
And I certainly thought about that.
Having space to spread out was important.
The tours have become,
we're really a shining jewel
in the crown of this renovation.
We've been renovating
for almost over 15 years,
and we're just finished phase three,
which was special collections.
And we're still really
benefiting from that limelight.
And that's been very important.
And collections conservators
do a lot of things
that aren't at the bench,
as many of us know,
and to have the space to meet
and the space to do
training, and hold workshops,
both internally or bringing people in
has been very important for us.
- For us I think I'll specifically focus
on our education and outreach program.
I had to fight really hard
when we were looking at the
square footage of our lab.
And when you get the blank slate,
which all of us have now,
it's hard to parse out the space
and recognize, especially for me,
who was relatively new
to the Illinois program
and didn't have a lot of experience
with that their needs were going to be,
to figure out how much square
footage we needed for each.
And I had to end up fighting really hard
for our all-purpose conference classroom,
what have you space.
But that was the best
argument I think I made,
because we bring so many workshops,
graduate school classes, tours,
advancement opportunities,
et cetera,
through that space that it
has paid for itself tenfold.
And because we're a
land-grant institution,
because we have that outreach
to the community mentality
already built in to the library,
and our library pushes very, very hard
for all of our librarians to go out
and do things for the community
and do things around campus, et cetera,
that classroom space has been invaluable
to allow us to do that.
And I can't imagine being
as successful as we are
in bringing people in,
and engaging people,
and making people understand
what conservation is,
that's not a battle that,
fortunately, I have to fight.
People get it.
For whatever reason they do,
and a lot of that has to do with the fact
that we're constantly
putting ourselves out there,
we're constantly finding
reasons to bring people in.
So we're really closely tied now
with the graduate school of
library and information science,
and have a lot of faculty there
who are better understanding
preservation and conservation,
and better understanding
the needs of that program
and how the graduate students
can come get experience there
and then go out and become
special collections librarians
who have understanding of conservation.
And that's been a really
important thing for us,
that classroom space and building that in
has been really useful.
- I think for UVA,
we've renovated or built
a conservation lab.
But I think the most
important non-treatment space
is the way tow bug-killer freezer laughs)
I think the freezer is in
the preservation office
with the book repair,
and having space to spread out the boxes
and give a quick initial vacuum
and then load up the freezer
and stage all of that
is really, really important,
and I think everyone who
works in a library knows
that all sorts of things come in
from all sorts of previous
storage situations,
and that you need to be
ready to roll with it,
whether it's bugs or mold or
just lots and lots of dirt
and mud dauber nests and what have you.
So I think in terms of
our overall program,
there's never enough room for that,
and we're looking at building a
UVA is looking at building
a second remote-storage
high-density facility,
and we are strongly advocating
for a treatment facility there
so that we have room to spread out
and room to stage boxes
and room to put totes and
plastic bags and so on.
In terms of the conservation lab,
I think the lab is so small
that I had to think about
treatment in the conservation lab
but then where could I
stash other workflows.
So I have the Minter welder,
as Bill well knows,
in the stacks of the special
collections building,
and that's just where it fits
and where the workflow fits.
Kinda.
But what has been a real success
is me giving up control of the photo-doc.
Originally the plan had been
to somehow fit a little copy
stand and lights and camera
in the conservation lab.
And I said,
"Space is too much at a premium,"
and UVA has a huge digitization workflow.
At this time there are four copy stands
with very current cameras,
very fancy lights,
all the computers they need,
all the student workers they need,
and they get funded and
everything gets upgraded
on a regular basis.
So I partnered with them and said,
"Hey, since you're
digitizing things anyway,
"if I need a couple of photos of things
"can I come in?"
"Of course, no problem."
So the benefit to me is
I don't have to pay for cameras,
I don't have to know
how the software works,
I don't have to do quality control,
or figure out how to
save files the right way.
There are students who take pity on me
and do it for the old lady
who doesn't know computers. (laughs)
And on the other hand
they get to see the conservation process
in before and after
because if I get things done
before they leave for the summer
they get to see that
Jefferson letter come back
looking much better,
and that's really exciting for them.
And I get to spy on their workflows
and make sure that all the
students are really well-trained
and handle things very carefully,
and that the staff in general
is very conscientious.
So that has been a real
benefit to my program
that I hadn't anticipated.
And honestly, I think if you
have a digitization workflow
that's a great way to go
because, at least in my world,
they get all the money, and
all the cameras, and students,
and so on.
- I'm tempted to give you
my first answer thought,
which was,
"The staff lounge."
(laughter)
Which I think for all of
us is pretty eye-opening
And amazing.
And I think it does actually serve
as a great gathering place,
and there are lots of people
that we run into for breaks.
There are a lot of informal meetings.
I had a discussion
about conservation space
with someone from the
Beinecke a couple of days ago
which was just over coffee.
And that kinda thing didn't happen
when were all so dispersed
because of the nature of,
Sterling is a beautiful building,
but Sterling is designed
in a very particular way
that's maze-like and really doesn't
have a lot of bring-you-together spaces
in terms of offices and staff.
I think, too, for us that
the lab has enough space,
and certainly the examination
room that we've built in
is a place where we're thinking
that's where we host scientists
who come to do micro-fading testing,
or we can host a large project
so that it's a sort of satellite space
for our West Campus operations.
It's a place where we could
host a workshop with Soyeon
from the YCBA.
And those things are all great.
I think the other nice
thing about this building
is that these shared spaces
are what really make a difference for us.
There are meeting rooms
for the first time ever
that are conveniently
located to our workspaces,
that are pleasant, that
can be scheduled easily.
This lecture and workshop,
what we're hosting today,
is so much easier to do,
and easier to direct people.
So I think that's been really
great for us to add that.
And certainly, because we are
really thinking and defining
conservation lab as also
conservation classroom.
We really do want students in.
And so it's great to have that space.
It's great to have this room
where we could hold a
lecture, or a small class,
or partner with someone.
The intake rooms that are
across the hall from us
from the Beinecke,
yesterday I looked at a book
that was delivered to us
that a curator is
considering for acquisition.
So that was easy to run across the hall
and take a look at that.
And so I think the synergies of our work,
and those relationships,
and the way that this new
building space has been designed
is an added plus in addition to
an unbelievably fabulous laboratory space.
- [Pilette] Okay so I'm
gonna open it to questions.
Do people have questions or do they wanna.
Ray, go ahead.
Anybody who wants to pass a
question in to the center aisle,
Marie will pick up.
But Ray, why don't you kick us off?
- [Ray] Okay, so while people are writing.
It seems like for a lot of you
getting this nice new space
was at the cost of moving
away from the reading room.
And I was just curious,
obviously there are pros and cons,
but have there been significant cons
being further away
from where you might be needed
for emergency sort of things
or consultation.
Or often there's a lot of
times people come for books
and they're in conservation
and not knowing where the are.
So I was wondering if some of you
or all of you could address
that sort of trade-off.
- [Pilette] Jen, you were nodding.
- Sure, I was nodding.
Yes, I would say that
I can think,
I mean our new space is
awesome and that's a huge pro.
It was the available space that we had,
but given the choice, I
would have had that new lab
in the main library,
absolutely positively.
There is no benefit to
not being near your stuff
and not being near the curators.
We're fortunate that, similar to Eliza,
at least preservation
is in the main building.
So when there is a crisis or something
there are trained staff to
be able to respond to that.
However, we've had an ongoing
challenge with shipping.
And the security of shipping
as well as the security of,
moving, not the actual transport,
which is its own issue,
but then the
"Did you get the stuff?"
"Yes, we got the stuff."
"How are you proving
that you got the stuff?"
"Well we go this stuff and this stuff,"
and going back to the
rare book room and saying
"We got it."
And then them accusing
when we send stuff back
of them then saying,
"You never sent the stuff."
"Yeah, we sent the stuff."
And it would be a lot easier
if we were all in the same building
and just carrying it down, and saying
"Here it is."
So that has been a huge challenge.
I think with 10 years of practice
we found a very workable
solution for that,
but unfortunately that
does frequently involve
people's personal cars,
which is not the way I'd like to do it.
But the fact is you can't always
coordinate shipping to come
and do last pickup at your building
and first pickup at the main library
and security-wise for special collections
you can't do anything but that.
You're not gonna leave
it sitting in the truck.
So that has been a real challenge.
And I think the biggest problem, honestly.
We haven't had that many
instances of someone
trying to find something
that's over in the lab.
Usually when that has happened
we can at least account for
it and get it over there
or whatever, so that really
hasn't been an issue.
But for us, the biggest challenge
has just been the transport of materials.
But then it's the
water-cooler conversations.
That's why I'm so jealous of here,
is you're with the
special collections staff.
So you can have those
over-coffee random conversations
that, being separated from
all of our special collections
we simply don't have.
And there's a lot of really
beneficial conversations
that aren't scheduled
at meetings that happen
that we now have to schedule time.
And we do encourage
all of our conservators
to basically schedule
office hours, more or less.
Now, the problem with us
is that we have five
distributed special collections.
So it's not like we can
just load, go one place,
and be there for an hour.
We have to rotate through all
of our special collections
to be able to make sure
that we're that available.
And they're not even all
in the main building.
But we do try very hard
to get out to all of those spaces.
I would say the one benefit
that we have with that
is that because I'm the
head of both preservation
and conservation,
I have offices in both buildings.
So if they have a conservation question,
they can often at least come to me
and I'll be around.
But that still isn't the
same as talking to the people
who are actually treating their objects,
which is not me.
- I would echo a lot
of what Jen has to say,
and then, I do have office
hours every Thursday.
I'm in special collections 9-12,
and I'm doing re-housing projects,
or I'm looking over books
that have been acquired
and adding them to my to-do list,
and being a general pest
so that people know I'm there to help out.
And then I have meetings there and so on.
And then when I have graduate students
they have office hours as well,
and I think wherever you wind up working,
you do have to learn how
to stage your projects.
So I think that's a really
valuable experience.
It can be tricky, though.
Unlike Jen,
I have a van driver that I
can just call up and say,
"Okay, we need to schedule a trip,"
and they think it's exciting
to come to the conservation lab
so they make it work.
And I just then have to get
someone from special collections
to ride shotgun and then stage the
roll it through the tunnels
to the loading dock.
But then, it happens infrequently enough
that everybody gets on board.
Then again, I have to work
really hard to stage treatements
and think,
"Okay, I'm gonna take in,"
like, one of my pictures,
there was a giant salter on the bench.
"Okay, I'm gonna take in the two salters,
"and that also means I have room
"for maybe two letters and that's it.
"And then when I finish the salters
"I can maybe take in some
architectural drawings,"
So I have to think really carefully
about what I can accommodate in my space
and get back to the reading
room in a timely fashion.
Things can't live out in my lab
because people need them back there
and they can't just pop
in and check a page.
Every now and then I've had a request,
"Well, a student has a project,"
and I'm like,
"Well okay, what date
range does she need it?"
and then I'll take pictures and send them.
But that's it.
- [Pilette] Is there a question?
Bob?
- [Bob] Yeah, a civilian question.
Actually two questions,
and one's very finite,
one could be very expansive.
The very finite is,
what's the difference between
conservation and preservation?
More expansive is, I see
from your presntations
a field that sounds like it's very new,
if 1974 is the earliest date we have.
And you presumably represent
the best of conservation
(laughter)
Is this a new field?
What was done before 1974?
- So I guess I'll take that.
I've got a mic.
(laughter)
The difference between
preservation and conservation,
in the library field,
library and archives,
is preservation is the umbrella operation.
In other words, it takes
care of all sorts of things.
It can deal with the HVAC,
the environmental conditions.
It can deal with commercial
binding, reformatting,
brittle paper, that sort of thing,
as well as conservation
and individual treatments.
So we're using preservation
in a very broad way.
Conservation is more narrow.
And the other question as
to the age of the field
depends upon what you,
I guess we would,
where do we—
(guests speaking off mic)
Do we start with the Florence flood?
Yeah, we start with the Florence flood.
1966 when the Arno flooded
there was a huge response
because of the number of
libraries and archives in Florence
that were totally inundated with water.
So people from all over the world
came to help rescue these materials.
And because of this,
there were experts, binders, scientists,
who for the first time
suddenly came together
and had to work together
rather than in their own
little studio or whatever.
And sharing what worked best.
At that point, the
field sort of marks that
as being the beginning of conservation
and library preservation
as the start of the
profession, as it were.
There's always been book binders,
there's always been restorers.
But this was the first time that people
really came together and
started sharing the knowledge
and deciding we need to do
something in a more formal way.
In Florence they started training programs
that really have been
working on for 50 years
the conservation of
materials that were rescued
as a result of that flood.
- If I could just add
to that a little bit.
Before the Florence flood there
was a man named Mr. Barrow
who was laminating
our founding father documents—
- [Teper] With the best
of intentions. (laughs)
- Yes, yes.
And the reason I know this
is because at the University
of Virginia we were very,
Mr. Barrow was at the Library
of Virginia in Richmond,
Charlotteville's just up the road.
We had oodles and oodles
of Jefferson, Washington,
Madison documents that
were being laminated.
Now, Mr. Barrow started out
doing research on brittle paper,
and he was very worried
about machine-made paper
from ground wood pulp
and he was a scientist and did research,
and was like,
"Gee all this acidic paper's very brittle,
"what are we gonna do?
"We can't reverse the acids,
"so let's laminate everything,"
like those driver's licenses
we got back in the day.
And since doing something to brittle paper
is worth doing well,
doing something to
founding fathers documents
is even better.
So that effort started up
before the Florence flood,
but then people started noticing
that plastic doesn't age very well,
and it started warping.
And so that is another sort
of thread of conservation,
where people were making the best efforts,
and they were doing it scientifically,
and they were taking notes
and doing research and so on,
and then there were
unintended consequences,
and I think Barrow lamination
is one area where conservation then says,
"Wow, one of our core concepts,
"is we have to be reversible.
"We have to be very
thorough in our research
"and very thorough in our approach,
"because with the best of intentions
"you can take all these
very important documents
"and cover them in plastic
"and turn them in to
little laminated placemats,
"and that's not what we wanna do."
So that's another—
- Right, yeah.
The Library of Congress and the,
well, Library of Congress got
started after Florence flood.
The national archives was the one
that was sort of leading that.
What has happened as a result of that
was they've also started undoing
a lot of the Barrow stuff.
Nancy?
- [Nancy] I would just
say another landmark
would be the Cooperstown
program in the 1950s
so that conservation of
painting and art began before
books and paper
- Yes, right.
Well that started,
Harvard had a training program.
Gettens started there, yeah.
So there's a long history.
The museum programs and the
field of museum conservation
is much older than the library.
But, I mean, you go
back to the Renaissance
there were restorers.
There was always somebody
who could clean a painting
or fix book.
- [Man] In-house
department for conserving—
- For library conservation is '70s
with the Library of Congress.
I think they're pretty much the first one.
I'm sorry?
- [Woman] Used to have binderies before.
- Binderies, yes.
In fact, at Columbia University
what was the conservation department
was, in fact, a bindery.
And they had big machines
that they took out.
Same thing at the Newberry Library.
There was a commercial bindery
that really repaired the
books, bound the books.
So it was in the '70s and '80s where
start seeing about how important,
the material culture.
What we call material culture.
And how important it is
to save that information for scholars.
So we can continue the
conversation over wine.
(laughter)
We have a reception—
(person speaks off mic)
Oh, one more question, yes.
- [Person In Audience]
It's related to the process
of developing the design.
You talked about the
professionals involved
(speaks off mic)
- I think for our program I can say,
because it was very
recent, I remember it well,
it's a combination.
So there was an architectural firm
who was responsible, Apicella and Bunton,
for the design of this facility.
As well as we had a
consultant, Sam Anderson,
who came in and did
(phone rings)
our initial space planning
for the preservation department in general
to help confirm our numbers.
They also stayed on to do
some technical cosulting
on some of the very unique
things to conservation labs,
because our architectural firm
had not done a conservation lab before.
One of the nice things is
I feel like we had a very nice partnership
with Apicella and Bunton
about conservation.
They were very interested
in what we wanted to do
and very open to our helping to design.
We could even send little
tracing paper drawings
of different kinds of layout ideas
and they were not the
least bit offended by that,
and able to turn it into something else
and to help us refine the details.
So I would say yeah,
it's a trio of a very
specialized architect,
our primary architectural firm,
and then the staff
themselves in conservation.
And also the myriad of
people that we've talked to
throughout the field who
have done labs before us.
All of us had contacts,
all of us had some previous experience.
You know what you like, you
know what you don't like,
and then you know you can
call Jen or Eliza to say,
"How did you make that work?
"What do I tell them?"
- [Pilette] I would say Jen
would be the next good one,
since you edited the book.
(laughter)
- Speaking from my experience,
I am jealous of being able
to bring in Sam Anderson
as a consultant.
Most of us don't have that kind of funding
available to us.
Or at least we didn't.
But I was fortunate,
so we had an architectural
firm, obviously,
who was involved in the design.
But they had no idea
what conservation was,
so there was a really big
learning curve for them
in trying to grapple,
"What is this space,
what does it need to do?
"Why do you need a dirty room?
"What's a dirty room?
"Why do you need a fume hood?
"Is this a lab?
"Do we need to build a chemistry lab?"
"No, it's not a chemistry lab,
"but it's like a chemistry lab, sorta."
So there was a lot of education there.
But where I really benefited was
our head of facilities within our library
who was obviously very integrated in this,
because all construction
goes through his office,
was an architect previous to that.
So he served as a really great translator,
because he understood the library,
he understood the needs.
I actually have a fantastic
relationship with him,
he really gets preservation,
and understood what conservation was
and what we were trying to do.
And so I could talk at him,
and he'd understand what I was saying.
And then he could talk to the architect,
and tell the architect what
the architect wanted to know,
which I had a really hard time doing.
So that relationship
was actually really,
really beneficial to us.
- [Pilette] Beth or
Eliza, anything to add?
- I would just say it's really important
for staff to take the time
to really think through
what they want in terms of workflows
and workflow adjacency.
And to really work out their arguments
as for why things need
to be the way they are.
I renovated and then designed a new lab
at the Smithsonian libraries,
and the fact that all the staff chimed in
and did mock-ups after
mock-up after mock-up
of the workspace
really made a huge difference.
And we were part of, at the Smithsonian,
a very big, big project.
We were just this little cog,
and so we would,
they produce what is it?
35% drawings, 55% drawings, 75% drawings,
and every time a big set
of drawings comes out,
we were given a half
hour with those drawings
to go through everything
and double-check that all the
people with the CAD programs
were doing everything correctly.
So we would just run into the room,
they would literally open the door,
we'd run in.
It was like,
"You take the plumbing,
"I'll take the electric,"
da da da da.
And we would just go
through it and say like,
"Okay, do they still have
the fume trunks in there?
"Do they still have the
exhaust fans on the roof?"
And then things would drop out.
And you would just put a little Post-It,
and the architect would say,
"Great, thank you.
"Okay thanks.
"Okay thanks."
Cuz they're not checking the work
the way you check the work.
They don't realize
that they've dropped a fan off the ceiling
which would, down the road,
mean a huge price tag.
And maybe the,
"Do you really need that fume trunk?
"Cuz we're gonna have to
punch a hole in the building."
So I think taking that time
and really being sure
of what your needs are
and what the things that
you need to check out
and the drawings are,
that makes a huge difference.
And then, in terms of my work at UVA,
when I was planning the
lab that didn't happen,
again being very passionate
and being very articulate
about why the things need
to be the way they are.
We had a collaborative
conservation facility,
that's what we kept calling it.
It was goinna be a paintings lab,
an art-on-paper lab, a
book conservation lab,
and then the office of the architect
wanted this huge sort of
pieces-of-buildings lab.
So very different operations,
but the architect kept saying,
"We don't want walls.
"We want everybody to collaborate.
"You've gotta be able to collaborate."
And it's like,
"We can walk through doors if need be.
"How 'bout giving us a
shared resource room,
"or library with the
kitchen and the lunch room
"and what have you.
"So-and-so's gonna be making dust
"because that's what architecture does.
"Paintings people aren't gonna want that
"anywhere near.
"And they're gonna need different lighting
"and different paint on the
walls than the book people,"
and so on.
So you have to keep making those arguments
because it's really
important that you win them.
- I know I'm standing in the way of wine,
(laughter)
but I will just very quickly
say that it is also sometimes helpful
to bring in somebody from the outside
who can say things.
And I've served that function.
I've been a consultant on
lab renovation projects
for other institutions.
And I'm saying the exact
same thing their staff is,
but because I don't work there,
there's a different level of listening.
And we don't all charge $50,000 a day.
So if you need an extra nudge
to say why it's important
there's people out there
who will give you a day or two or three
or a week of your time
that's affordable, and
it's just another voice
to add to the din of voices
that they hear every day.
- Alright.
Thank you very much,
and the wine is out the door to the right.
(applause)
(gentle xylophone jingle)